[Music]
this week people around the world are
pausing to remember
the six million victims of the holocaust
with the call
never forget for one man in california
forgetting
will never be possible but forgiveness
is something he excels in
ben tracy has the story ben stern is
pretty active for a 95 year old
but ever since his wife of more than 70
years went to a nursing home
the days have been long and lonely so he
decided
to find a roommate it never dawned on me
it's going to happen
he ended up with 31 year old leah
heitfeld
do you want a coffee another cup i have
a cup
okay at 95 is she keeping you younger
yes
i walk and i take a shot of vodka every
day
that'll keep you young that will keep me
going
and so when he and leah first got to
know each other on the rooftop of his
apartment in berkeley
their gender and the 64-year age gap
is not even close to being the most
unique thing about this odd couple
how did the two of you first talk about
this
he knew i was a young german girl and
he sat down and the first thing he said
is leah i want you to know
your third generation you're not
responsible for what happened
stern was a teenager in poland when the
nazis rose to power
he lived in the warsaw ghetto and
survived nine concentration camps
including auschwitz if i could
take you with me
for 24 hours to outreach
you'll come out affected the rest of
your life
ben's entire family died in the
holocaust
i lost seven brothers
and one sister i lost
my mother and my father
i can't forget i don't want to forget
aside from leah being german something
else
had to be acknowledged so my
grandparents my father's parents were
active nazis
i can't leah
is not guilty
about what her grandparents did
i grew up in a small town in northern
germany and
jewish life did not exist i'm still a
reminder
of that time and that he is
capable to to welcome me with such
warmth
and how much forgiveness how much
compassion compassion yeah now this
granddaughter of two nazis
is getting a master's degree in jewish
studies
if there's a gut in heaven it created
angels and when she came
on the scene i felt
it is the perfect
person to attach
to my history to make it complete
a history that has shown him the worst
of what humans can do
and the best in who we can be for cbs
this morning saturday
ben tracy berkeley california